today the mattwell show Prince Harry
continues to seek privacy by spilling
his guts in front of every camera that
he can find he's become a sad broken
whiny shell of a man thanks in large
part to the awful woman he married many
lessons to be learned from that we'll
discuss today also Kevin McCarthy
finally wins the speakership after 15
votes but not before making a number of
extremely important concessions it was
all a win for the so-called far-right
Republicans and a man is wanted for
questioning after shooting and killing
an armed robber in Texas the shooting
may have been arguably legally
questionable but I'll explain why I
would never vote to convict if I was on
the jury in our daily cancellation The
Young Turks claimed to have demolished
me will watch the video and see how they
did all of that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're someone who has always wanted
to read and understand the Bible but
you're not sure where to start then
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension the Bible and ear podcast
is currently the most popular religion
podcast in the US millions of people
have listened to it and twice it's hit
the number one spot on Apple podcast in
the Bible in the year father Mike
Schmitz reads the entire Bible in 30 uh
in 365 daily episodes providing helpful
commentary reflection and prayers along
the way what better way to start the new
year you can find the Bible into your
podcast with father Mike Schmitz for
free and your favorite podcast app or on
YouTube unlike any other Bible podcast
Bible in a year follows a special
reading plan that organizes the books of
the Bible in a way that helps listeners
understand the story you can get this
reading plan at ascensionpress.com Walsh
if you want to start reading and more
importantly understanding the Bible this
year go to ascensionpress.com Walsh to
download the reading plan for free
that's ascensionpress.com Walsh to
download the reading plan for free
well Prince Harry really wants his
privacy he's searched everywhere for
privacy he's gone and turned over every
Rock looking for it he's trekked through
the forests and over mountains in
pursuit of his privacy he's looked for
privacy and interviews with Oprah and in
podcasts and documentaries and has just
released Netflix series and now he's
looking for privacy by publishing an
autobiographical book which will be
released this week and which he promoted
in a 60 Minutes interview and in an
interview on ITV in Britain and in a
Good Morning America interview and then
in an appearance on The Late Show later
this week he's gone in front of every
camera in the world and stepped on every
stage and milked every moment under
every Spotlight he could find all
because he and his wife just want
privacy his upcoming book A tell-all
Memoir much like the type often written
by those who desire privacy more than
anything apparently goes into great
detail but all of his squabbles and
beefs and feuds with his family Harry
has become the world's foremost leader
in the field of over sharing and this
book is exactly what you'd expect from
someone with those kinds of credentials
he not only airs his family's dirty
laundry publicizing and cashing in on
all of his Petty resentments and
familial disputes he also provides
intimate details that even the most
Ardent Harry and Megan fans if such
people could possibly exist would not
have ever solicited for example
he reveals that this is what he says in
his books his book that he once suffered
frostbite on his genitals
Harry will not even allow his privates
to remain private and yet he just wants
privacy the title of the book spare is a
reference to Harry's feelings of being
the spare the outcast in his family
poor Harry poor poor put upon oppressed
multi-millionaire world famous Harry he
is in so much pain he says and his wife
is also in pain pain and suffering is a
phrase that has come up in multiple
interviews about his book and before his
book talked a lot about it his pain and
suffering his wife's pain and suffering
complains about it and accuses his
family of being complicit quote unquote
in that pain and suffering the general
response to this public Vendetta that
Harry has against his own family has
been to parse through his words trying
to discern what is true what isn't what
needs more context Etc
now personally I have no idea if Harry
is telling the truth or not and I don't
care every family has turmoil and drama
every member of every family has been
both wrong and right both bully and
bullied
families are complicated
and if you're hearing one person's
version of a dispute you could be quite
certain that the other people concerned
those being painted as villains would
have a very different take on things if
you asked them and if they were willing
to answer
this is why family issues should be kept
within the family
you don't have to like every member of
your extended family but there's never a
time when it's necessary or good or
Justified to turn your family drama into
a public spectacle
and this by the way is a lesson that
many people in our society ought to take
to heart now most of us aren't in a
position where we can complain about our
families in a 60 Minutes interview many
people probably would like to do that
but there's just no interest
um yet it is quite common to see people
on a smaller scale
and yet the largest scale available to
them airing their dirty laundry and
family disputes in public to people
around them on social media especially
they provide one side of a complicated
story to an audience that is not
involved that has no business being
involved and that can't do anything with
the information you're giving them or do
anything about the problem to help
resolve it anyway
which is why you know if you have an
issue with your family you should
confront your family and your close
friends in person
tell them how you feel
might even get angry
you might yell I mean these things
happen in families that's normal but in
public
there should be a united front
so you for instance might think that
your brother is an idiot
you might tell him so to his face
but if someone outside your family calls
him an idiot you should take offense at
that and respond accordingly he's an
idiot but he's your idiot because you're
family
this is one of the many things that
Harry gets wrong but it's not just his
family that he feels victimized by he
says it's also the Press
the couple have been on a never-ending
press tour for the past like two years
now doing everything in their power to
attract attention from the press and yet
they are oppressed by the same press
that they can't stop talking to
during his 60 Minutes interview he
explains that the media is bigoted
bigoted against Megan and it's not only
actually the media that's bigoted but uh
listen to this
what Megan had to go through was was
similar in some part to what Kate and
what committee went through very
different circumstances but then you add
in the race element which was what the
Press British press jumped on straight
away I went into this incredibly naive I
had no idea the British press was so
bigoted hell I was probably bigoted
you're the relationship with with Megan
you'd think you were bigoted before the
relationship with Megan I don't know
put it this way I didn't see
what I now see
you don't know if you're a bigoted how
could you not know if you were bigoted
or not now this is mostly empathy virtue
signaling of course here Harry is uh
doing the work and doing the work means
baselessly accusing everyone including
yourself of bigotry
but that's not to say that he that he's
being entirely insincere it's clear that
the man has been genuinely brainwashed
into the religion of wokism and in that
religion bigotry is the original sin but
not shared by all people shared only by
members of the white race
this is uh it's the the original sin of
white people and uh people who are not
white have no sins at all
it is a hazy undefinable sort of evil
shared by every member of the white race
Harry doesn't remember any specific
occasion of being bigoted he never
harbored any racial animosity towards
non-white people and yet
even though this by definition means
that he was not racially bigoted he
still cannot declare himself to have not
been bigoted
Because the actual belief of the woke
white person is that he himself cannot
speak to his own racism or lack thereof
he is not an expert in his own thoughts
and feelings
it's up to a member of the racial victim
class to determine whether he is racist
or not from one moment to the next
he cannot speak to his own motivations
and intentions but they can
and now that Harry is married to a a
member of that racial victim class uh
she can she can attest to his
non-bigotry now
but before her she was not there to
absolve him and that's the way he sees
it
and finally speaking of Megan um
this is Maybe
the most important or at least most
useful point for most of us let her be a
warning to men everywhere because
although Harry is no victim no martyr
much as he wishes to be he is still a
pitiful and pathetic figure a broken
shell of a man
he's still rich and famous but he's no
longer respected
and that's the worst thing the worst
thing a man can lose is respect
a man can live and be happy without much
money without many things but the loss
of respect is what truly devastates and
in many cases can prove fatal
and Harry has become a man who is no
longer respectable in large part because
he married a woman who does not respect
him this is the influence that a woman
can have over a man her feelings about
him often become a sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy
I think it was G.K Chesterton who noted
that the uh he noted the the positive
end of this kind of relationship
explaining how the lesson of Beauty and
the Beast is that a man must be loved in
order to become lovable Beauty lifts up
the Beast her love helping him to become
the man he was meant to be but a bad
woman can have the opposite effect
turning a prince back into a beast in
this case a whiny petulant baby beast
but a beast all the same
my wife has helped me to become a better
man because she loves and respects me
and when you love and respect something
you want it to be the best version of
itself but then there are the Meghan
markles of the world who will break a
man instead of building him up bringing
out his worst aspects while smothering
all that was good in him this is the the
nightmare scenario that has chased many
men away from Marriage as we've
discussed over the last few days but
the good news is that it's pretty easy
to spot the Meghan markles
so easy that most of us had the actual
Meghan Markle figured out after
listening to her speak for like 45
seconds
either Harry didn't see it because he
allowed himself to be blinded by her
good looks or wouldn't be the first man
to fall into that trap or he did see it
and decided to move forward anyway
perhaps partially motivated by his
simmering resentment for his family
whatever the case
there's a very basic checklist that a
man should refer to when dating a woman
and the woman should have a similar
mental checklist in mind when dating a
man the first and biggest question
and the one that a Discerning man should
be able to answer rather easily is does
she respect you
you should be able to figure that out
pretty quickly
what what an important skill for a man
to learn is this is to is to be able to
identify when he's not being respected
also does she cheer you on does she root
for your success and happiness or is she
more focused on her own
does she desire for you to have a close
relationship with your family
or does she want to isolate you from
everyone you know and love
does she talk about herself all the time
or does she spend more time asking
questions about you is she sincere is
she kind
or do does she only appear to be kind in
public but then you see her rolling her
eyes behind the scenes does she have
empathy
these are the questions to ask yourself
when Discerning marriage now it's
possible that a very gifted phony may be
able to deceive you on many or even all
of these points but most phonies are not
that gifted Meghan Markle certainly
isn't
which is why I was able to answer all of
these questions about her about five
minutes after discovering that she
existed
okay I didn't even know she existed five
minutes later I knew everything I needed
to know about her
Harry should have been able to answer
them but if he did
he ignored the answers
and now he is paying the price
now let's get to our headlines
experts are highlighting new identity
theft threats to watch out for in 2023
some tactics include scams targeting
specific ethnic groups and those with
limited English proficiency payment app
scams will likely continue to increase
as their popularity increases that's why
it's so important to understand how
cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day your
personal information gets exposed so
often that it's dangerously easy for a
cyber criminal to steal your identity
but protecting your identity can be easy
with LifeLock by Norton LifeLock detects
and alerts you to potential identity
threats you may not spot on your own
like loans taken out in your name if you
do become a victim of identity threats
theft rather a dedicated us-based
restoration specialist will work to fix
it for you nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions in all businesses but it's
easy to help protect yourself with
Lifelock Identity Theft Protection
Starts Here join now and save up to 25
off your first year at lifelock.com
Walsh that's a lifelock.com Walsh for 25
off
headline from the daily wire here are
the concessions house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy gave to Republican holdouts to
win their support article says after
days of negotiations and 15 roll call
votes California representative Kevin
McCarthy became house Speaker early
Saturday morning after reportedly giving
major concessions to a group of
Republican holdouts increasing the
influence of some of the chamber's most
conservative members McCarthy's
concessions include changes to how the
house is run placing members of the
House Freedom caucus on key committees
and the creation of a committee to
conduct a major investigation into the
FBI which for my money is the most
important concession that they
um were able to exact or or gain
uh Floyd representative Matt Gates says
I feel the American people won I feel
the House Representatives will be a
healthier Institution
many of these things have been resisted
by Kevin McCarthy as early as Monday now
we have an Exquisite rules package while
some critics accuse the holdouts of
grandstanding in the end McCarthy
reportedly gave in to much of the
demands of the block according to the
freedom caucus chairman representative
Scott Perry the juice was worth the
squeeze Perry alongside other members of
the opposition posted lists of
concessions they had gained from
McCarthy to earn their vote these
included getting a vote on a border
security plan a budget that doesn't
allow the debt ceiling to increase an
end to all coveted mandates and funding
a term limit vote single subject bills
and allowing at least 72 hours given for
members to read the bills
another key provision is allowing for
any member uh to introduce a motion to
vacate the chair meaning that members
can demand a vote to remove the speaker
from the position if he doesn't live up
to his end of the bargain another
concession that was discussed throughout
the week was creating an open amendment
process to bills making it easier for
lawmakers to change bills during debate
um
members of the freedom caucus will also
reportedly be placed on the rules
committee and the Appropriations
Committee committee is crucial to how
the house runs and how funding is doled
out
the house will vote on the rules package
on Monday setting up another potential
fight among Republicans Texas
representative Tony Gonzalez a moderate
has already promised to vote against the
rules package Okay so
these are these are the rules that have
been agreed to as proposals but now they
have to actually vote on them and get
them passed through that way
whatever happens when they vote on the
rules this is still an enormous success
um
and uh a blueprint that should be
followed
because here we have actual
conservatives
who are extracting concessions from the
establishment
they they were able to bend the
establishment to their will by using the
leverage that they had available to them
so they couldn't do everything right it
was it was only what it was like 20
people
and so they didn't have enough they
didn't have the numbers to actually put
somebody in place that they wanted
but they had they had Leverage
they had leverage to achieve something
and they achieved it
because even to get now what what's
Kevin McCarthy agreed to this this tells
what kind of guy Kevin McCarthy is
it shouldn't have required this long
standoff between the two factions to get
these concessions in place these are all
rules and proposals that should have
been in place to begin with
tells you everything you need to know
about Kevin McCarthy in fact if you
weren't up until this point maybe you're
not paying attention to this drama you
don't care that much I understand that
uh but maybe you didn't quite understand
you didn't realize you did you were
looking at this and saying what's the
big deal with Kevin McCarthy why not
just vote for him well this should tell
you this is it
the fact that they had to go through 15
votes to get this guy to agree to the
things that I just listed
which are things that every
Republican really every member of the
House Representatives should agree to
um things like giving
members of the House time to read the
bills before they're voted on
they need to get that that's a
concession that Kevin McCarthy agreed to
they had to beat this out of him
something as simple as hey maybe before
we vote on the bills we should read them
single issue bills meaning like let's
let's focus on one Topic at a time stop
taking every piece of legislation as an
opportunity to piggyback it and and put
all of your pet projects and all that
kind of stuff and earmarks onto it
investigate the FBI's abuses of power
that should be the most automatic thing
of all
and other similar sorts of things so
these are all very common sense
they're not even
you know if this is what counts as
conservative now well then that that
also tells you what you need to know
and this only happened because again the
supposed far right the radicals
which some people object to that label I
don't
like I'm finding myself being labeled or
radical I don't consider that to be an
insult so if that's what you want to
call them then fine
whatever you call them they were able to
get these concessions by using the
leverage that they had and this is a a
success
and it does it just the the people the
conservatives
who were objecting to this all week
it makes you wonder what they were
really objecting to
like this was the worst case scenario
okay there's there's you could just hand
Kevin McCarthy this viewership and and
get nothing out of him whatsoever
so you can do that
it's hard to see that as a win
or you could try to get something out of
it you can use the leverage that you
have you have something right through
these these members of the house they
had something that Kevin McCarthy needed
which was their vote so that he could
become Speaker of the House
so they could just give it to him for
nothing
or try to get something in exchange for
it
why would you give it to him for nothing
and what's the downside I never
understood what was supposed to be the
downside
of trying to get something out of this
yeah this establishment shell is going
to probably end up being a speaker of
the house regardless because he has most
of the votes that's probably what's
going to end up happening
but if you have a little bit of Leverage
to get something out of it
um and it's not like you're getting
something personally for yourself
the American people are getting
something out of it if you have that
ability what's the downside
what's the worst case scenario
you had conservatives uh some
conservatives panicking all week this is
this is an embarrassment this is an
embarrassment
this is actually democracies with
Democratic processes supposed to be we
want them to fight and argue amongst
themselves I wish they fought and argued
more than they did
you know you read the stories of what
the um
of what Congress was like like in the in
the early 19th century
and you have members of Congress like
taking you know pokers out of the fire
and whack each other over the head with
it I wish that was still happening not
only because C-SPAN would be a lot more
entertaining but because that that shows
that they're actually
fighting for like that's what they're
supposed to do this is this is a it's
deliberation and sometimes deliberations
can get you know a little bit heated
and if they turn violent as far as I'm
concerned no big deal
but then this was not even violence okay
this wasn't that they weren't they
weren't uh this this was not a Royal
Rumble
this was a this was a debate this was a
you know a
process of compromise is what it was
so I never understood it what what was
the downside never understood the
downside was supposed to be okay uh this
is from the daily wire armed customer
shoots Robert dead and returns stolen
money in Houston Taqueria
the carrier how do you pronounce it a
man shot and killed a robbery says it's
a taco shop is what it is can we just
call it that it's a taco shop
a man shot and killed a robbery suspect
at a at a uh Taco Shop in Houston on
Thursday before returning the stolen
money to other patrons according to
authorities the incident happened around
11 30 pm and was caught in surveillance
video which has been viewed online
millions of times Witnesses told
officers that a masked African-American
man wearing all black clothing a black
ski mask and black gloves walk into the
restaurant pointed what appeared to be a
firearmer customers while demanding
their money according to Houston Police
while the person was walking around the
restaurant taking money from patrons One
customer sitting in a booth with another
person quickly stood up as soon as the
suspect passed by pulled out a gun as
seen in the surveillance video police
said the armed Patron shot the suspect
multiple times before collecting the
stolen money which he then returned to
the others this individual and other
patrons then left the scene leaving the
police to ask the public for help and
identifying the shooter as he has wanted
for questioning the Houston Police
Department shared surveillance images of
who they believe was the armed customer
described as a white or Hispanic man as
well as his 1970 19 or 1980s model
pickup truck with no bed no charges have
been filed police said on Friday press
release
um
and Houston Police Lieutenant R Wilkins
said the now dead suspect was
brandishing a plastic pistol uh possibly
an Aerosoft or possibly a little BB
pistol no one else in the restaurant was
injured the news report noted
investigators encouraged the shooter and
victims to contact the Houston Police
Department division at uh
and then there's the phone number I'm
actually going to give the phone number
away because I don't trust the police
I don't trust that they just that they
just want to talk he's not in trouble we
just want to talk
and I'm sure eventually they'll find him
and they'll have the conversation that
they want to have and I very much hope
that he gets a lawyer before that
happens
here now as as the daily wire report
notes this the video of this incident
was on surveillance video that was
released
and the police originally I think was
the police originally who released a a
version of the surveillance video but
they cut it off right before the shots
were fired and there was the full
unedited clip that made its way onto the
internet uh as it often does which shows
the entire incident and we're not going
to show that to you here but you can if
you really are interested you can see it
for yourself if you do go
and watch the full video what you'll see
is that uh yeah the guys he's he's
holding up the place he has a gun turns
out to not be a real gun nobody knows
that okay he's intentionally of course
trying to make everyone believe that
it's a real gun so this is all on him
and um as he's kind of walking by this
uh this Good Samaritan the Good
Samaritan pulls out a gun shoots him
multiple times
and then the bad guy falls to the ground
and the Good Samaritan walks over is
still shooting him and then appears this
is what it appears to this is what
appears to happen it appears
that he picks up
the bad guy's gun and then shoots him
one more time while he's on the ground
that's what appears now it's pretty
grainy but that's kind of how it appears
to happen
so
there are many as this video has been
passed around
there are plenty of people online saying
that this was not a good shoot this bad
shoot and uh he should be charged with a
crime for this
and I will say that legally okay
according to the letter of the law I'm
not a lawyer but and all the laws how
they treat these things are different
this is Texas we're talking about so but
probably it would it would stand to
reason I would be um
I'm sympathetic to the argument that
legally according to the letter of the
law he might have gone
over the line not on the first few shots
but on the last one in particular if
it's if it actually is true that he
picked up the guy's gun and then while
he's lying there shot him another time
um certainly you would think at least
that last shot
May legally be over the line
and that might be a large part of what
the Houston Police want to talk to him
about
but with that said
that's letter of the law
with that said if I'm on the jury
and I wish that I could be I can't
because I don't live in Texas but uh if
I'm on the jury there is no way in hell
I vote to convict this guy there's no
way I find him guilty This Is Not Guilty
All The Way
for me
uh is not going to happen
and if it was eleven to one that's what
it would be this would be 12 Angry Men
as well that's that's what we would see
playing out in real in real life
no way I vote to send this guy to prison
even if it was over the line legally
still I wouldn't
because it's it is my opinion that um
first of all
when you decide to grab a gun and commit
a crime a violent crime like this you
start shoving a gun in people's face
trying to take their money from them you
have forfeited your rights as far as I'm
concerned that that's that's the
approach that I would take on a jury you
have forfeited your rights your rights
are out the window
that's what you've decided to do you
have effectively thrown your own life
away you have sent the message that you
that your life is is you know your life
does mean anything to you
um that was your decision
and also you know with you you are
okay you're the one with premeditation
so you decided you were going to do this
this guy who's now this scumbag is now
dead
he decided he wanted to do this he had
pre-meditation he was thinking this
through he didn't think it through that
much apparently okay he didn't think
enough about it but he was thinking
about it so he had you know he goes into
this somewhat prepared for what he's
about to do because he's the one doing
it
everybody else there they're just trying
to enjoy their dinner they're not
expecting this
you're putting them in this position out
of nowhere in this life or death
situation and it's not fair to expect
them to respond to it exactly correctly
so you can after the fact parse through
it and sift through it a Monday Morning
Quarterback and say well according to
the law yeah but nobody's sitting there
with a with a book of with the the law
book in front of them you know flipping
through it what am I allowed to do here
no you're put in this position
adrenaline takes over
it's it's fight or flight some people
are a lot of people are flight this
guy's fight
and I think we need more people with the
fight Instinct and adrenaline takes over
and this is what it does so if if one or
two of the shots is over the line who
cares
you know whose fault that is it's the
guy who's laying dead in a bloody puddle
on the on the ground that's his fault
maybe you should think about this see
this this is we need violent criminals
to think about this we need them to be
afraid we need them to fear for their
lives
before they carry out the crime so that
maybe they won't carry it out to begin
with
so if other potential violent criminals
are seeing that video and saying wow uh
man
you know I walk in and just start
robbing people there might be somebody
in there who's you know got a gun is it
hopped up on adrenaline
and I might I might throw my whole life
away like I could go into this taco shop
and Rob everybody and and you know make
off with 43 dollars and some change
I could do that
but then
in pursuit of that end I might end up
dead on the floor
I might die on the floor on the dirty
floor of this Taco Shop in Houston
at 11 o'clock at night that might be the
end of my story we want them to think
about that
now more than ever because our cities
have been overrun
by violent criminals
they're uh they've been given
essentially free reign to do whatever
they want people live in fear the
government has abandoned the citizens to
a large extent
and so really the only way of restoring
order any semblance of order and justice
is for citizens to start defending
themselves and and each other
it's either that or just or or people
line up to be victims
and part of the way we've ended up this
situation is that the law extends
enormous Grace to Violent criminals
and does everything in its power to
let the violent criminal off the hook or
to be as lenient as possible that's what
the law does the court systems do
okay they they do everything in their
power to be as lenient as possible to
these kinds of violent criminal scumbags
like the guy that's robbing the Taco
Shop
well I think that's what we need to do
for these citizens who fight back
be as lenient as possible
extend every available Grace
even to the point of absurdity because
that's what we do in the in favor of the
of the violent criminals
and that's how our cities have turned
all of them into you know like Mad Max
no I would do that I would do that for
the citizens to fight back I would say
Hey you know
hopped up on adrenaline that last shot
the video is kind of grainy can't really
see what's happening who knows uh hey
you know maybe he picked up the guy's
gun maybe he thought that the guy had
another gun maybe he twitch maybe the
guy's laying there on the ground he
twitched his arm it looked like he was
reaching for another gun so he had to do
what he had to do now do I buy that
excuse necessarily probably not but
that's the that is the level of benefit
of doubt that I would give in a
situation like this
and let all the violent criminals know
this is the benefit of that we get of
all you walk in there you instigate
something like this all of the benefit
of the doubt goes to the citizens who
might
kill you in response they get the
benefit of that you get none
we're gonna throw the book at you
but for anyone who might shoot you in in
while you're carrying out this crime
we're going to flip through that book
looking looking for any loophole we can
find to let them off the hook
all right
this is from the daily wire players from
uh Raiders and Chiefs pray at Midfield
following the game in which teams
honored Demar Hamlin several players
from Las Vegas Raiders and the Kansas
City Chiefs prayed on the field Saturday
evening at the conclusion of the matchup
between the two teams following Buffalo
Bills safety Demar Hamlin's medical
emergency during a game earlier this
week Fox reported that players from both
teams wore athletic gear that featured
statements like love for Demar and
Hamlin strong as a way of showing
support prior to kickoff the report said
that the first digit of the 30 yard
lines at the Allegiant Stadium were
painted blue because that was the
Buffalo Bills color
um
and there were other examples too of uh
the teams praying and that sort of thing
and I bring this up because this this is
one thing that people have remarked on
um
and yeah I noticed it too after the
Demar Hamlin incident last Sunday night
that you know the the the open
religiosity that's on display
uh very often in our culture there's a
mass shooting a tragedy
and if you so much as talk about prayer
you get attacked well your thoughts and
prayers don't do anything
in this case that wasn't happening now
it's kind of sad
that in our culture it's okay to talk
about prayer and thoughts and prayers
when a football player gets injured but
not when like 15 people are dead in mass
shooting
but prayer should be applied in all
cases is what I'm trying to say but
the the the religiosity the the the
faith put on display football players on
the field praying talking about their
faith this is maybe came as a surprise
to people who are not football fans and
have and you know are now following this
one football related story because of
you know obviously broke through Beyond
just football fans but those who are
football fans
this is not a surprise at all because
we're fully aware that football players
have always been quite religious in fact
before you know you go before the Colin
Kaepernick thing when the NFL earned for
itself you know from because of the
actions of the the actions mainly of
corporate office but also some players
in the field it earned for itself this
reputation as being woke before that you
may recall
people the complaints would be kind of
the opposite people would often complain
when you had football players at press
conferences post-game press conferences
thanking God and and saying that you
know God was on their side and you know
all that kind of thing you have people
complaining and say oh God doesn't care
about your the outcome of your football
game
that used to be the complaint
but I never did complain about that
because I think it's a it's a wonderful
thing it's one of the things that I that
I like about football
is that it has in fact this has come out
we talked about it last week this is you
know this this has come out in the
complaints that the left and the media
has about football we we read through
that one I think it was a Washington
Post or New York Times article they're
both the same but complaining that
football is religious it's patriotic
it's Macho
and yeah it is all those things it's
always been those things
now you have the NFL you have the
corporate NFL that's trying to change
some of those things
but football as a sport remains
um
you know among other things that you
know it it has a it has a very
oftentimes because of the the players
they tend to be religious as a kind of
religious
flavor to it uh
all right
meanwhile over on well another Demar
Hamlin thing over on Fox Sports Michael
Strahan is still traumatized by
the totally benign Skip Bayless tweet we
talked about last week but he's still
upset about let's play this
and and you spoke about humanity and I
think but there were things done here by
someone here at this network that were
inhumane
and and we sit here and we talk about
how good and I'm sorry to take it this
way but this this route but I just I
just felt like
sensible people and sensible human
beings have a heart and they understand
that that your words and what you say
really have an impact not only on that
young man's family and and and so all
the attention should be on this young
man his recovery for offensible people
like us here to say that it didn't
affect anybody at this network nobody
just Network minded that's a lie
obviously didn't talk to us because it
matters to us and it matters to any
sensible human being that this young
man's life was bigger than any football
game this young man will hopefully be
back and forget about football but just
have a life and his family has him
that's the most important thing and and
I think that was kind of like a little
bit in all of this
good lord well for Many religious many
football players are religious as we
talked about but then there are others
especially in the sports media side of
it who for them their religion is uh
it's a religion of of virtue signaling
and that's what you saw there inhumane I
mean he's talking again about a tweet
it's tweeted by a sports analyst
wondering about this scheduling you know
how the NFL is going to reschedule the
game that's inhumaneous inhumane to talk
about that
and then the funny thing is that
everyone insisted
because it was a question after they
decided to cancel the game
which nobody objected to that it made
sense to do
um
but there was a question like well what
are you going to do now how are you
going to how are we gonna handle this
because it's towards the end of season
playoff implications like
uh the NFL is a multi-billion Dollar
business like these are things you have
to think about it's that it's it's got
to be a conversation at some point but
everyone insisted that we can't talk
about it but do not talk about it for
some reason we weren't allowed to even
talk about it and then the NFL comes up
with their solution to this because they
canceled the game they came up with a
solution and they came up with the
dumbest solution this convoluted like
involving coin flips and everything else
and then people are complaining about
the solution they came up with well we
weren't allowed to talk about the what
the solution would be because of you
know the virtue signaling happening
from the sports commentators all right
one other thing this is from the other
wire flying car prototypes are starting
to take off science fiction is one step
closer to reality as several companies
debut working prototypes for flying cars
the American startup ASCA showed off its
A5 model at the 2023 Consumer
Electronics Show the A5 is an electric
vertical takeoff and Landing vehicle
roughly the size of a standard SUV that
is reportedly capable of driving at 70
miles per hour on the road and flying at
speeds of up to 150 miles per hour
all I want to say about this is that the
flying car thing you know it's it's the
kind of thing that you think sounds
really great and cool
when you're a kid
before you're able to drive yourself and
then you get a license and you get out
on the roads and you realize what a
terrible idea this would actually be
because the vast majority of people
can't drive on the ground let alone
driving in the sky it's amazing that
most Americans Drive every day for
decades and yet never figure out how to
do it I mean the roads are are infested
with people behind they're driving these
big chunks of metal 70 miles per hour
and they're just sitting behind the
wheel they have no idea what they're
doing or anything
how can you do something every day and
yet not know how to do it
but this is the case just yesterday I
was you know one example so many sitting
sitting at a typical experience sitting
at a stoplight
I'm in the right hand lane it's a turn
lane turn only Lane there's one car in
front of me
and as always that car is just sitting
there at the red light
he's got all there's there are no cars
coming the other direction he's sitting
there at the red light pondering the
mysteries of the universe rather than
turning which you can do
you can turn on red I mean are there any
states left in the United States of
America where you can't turn right on
red
does that exist anywhere how is it that
people still aren't acquainted with this
rule
this is I'm pretty sure every state in
the Union if you can turn right on red
unless there's a sign saying otherwise
so this guy isn't turning I'm beeping at
him he still isn't going finally we get
a green he turns then as I'm going up to
take my turn to turn my turn to turn
it's a green now a car that is not in
the turn lane turns right right in front
of me
so cars that are supposed to turn right
aren't cars that aren't supposed to turn
right are
and why do the guy do that well because
he was not in the Turn Only land he
landed he realized at the last minute he
wasn't in the lane well okay read the
signs and you wouldn't have this problem
or if you missed just go to the next
intersection turn right there hook up
with the path you wanted to take it's an
extra 45 seconds so you could take the
extra 45 seconds or risk a car accident
this is a calculation people make it's
like when they they're about to miss the
exit so they Veer across four lanes of
traffic you could die like you you might
die doing that
or just take an extra 45 seconds take
the exit that's one you know take one
exit up and flip around a couple extra
minutes
you got people in cars saying I would
rather be dead and possibly kill like 15
other people instead of taking a couple
a couple extra minutes because I missed
my exit
anyway
my point simply is we do not need to
give these people planes
that's all I'm trying to say
let's get to the comment section
order of the day
[Music]
make the New Year all about the new you
with genu cell skin care watch those
Fine Lines forehead wrinkles sagging
jawline dark marks skin redness and even
under eye bags disappear my talent
manager Tessa we just call her assistant
in these things so now it's okay it's
been a promotion uses genucel under eye
treatment to help get rid of the bags
under her eyes and she says it works
like a charm I ask her about it every
day and she tells me still working
that's the conversation we have in real
life genu cell skin care can help you
turn back the clock and look 5 10 even
15 years younger it's made for both
women and men say for all skin types and
works for all ages genucel promises
immediate effects and results that will
make you smile or get 100 of your money
back right now get gen yourself customer
favorite a deep firming vitamin C serum
it's absolutely free in every most
popular package you can hydrate your
skin while restoring your natural
vibrant glow visit genyourself.com Walsh
and use code wall should check out every
order is automatically upgraded to free
shipping that's genucel.com Walsh
genucel.com Welsh
football Rob says Matt is the only
married man I've ever seen who advocates
for marriage well then rob you hang
around some
really low quality men I don't know what
to tell you you know and I saw a lot of
comments like this as we've been talking
about this
topic over the last couple days and um
I've seen a lot of comments that are
saying oh every man I know hates
marriage has a terrible marriage
complains about his marriage every man I
know really every man you know
for me it's almost exactly the opposite
everyone in my immediate family parents
All My Siblings except the one who
became a nun
um the other uh four all of them are in
successful and happy marriages uh the
vast majority of the married people that
I know and who are around me are married
happily I didn't say perfectly but like
they're they're in functional marriages
here at the daily wire if you watch
Backstage on a typical uh show me Ben
Michael
Andrew clave and Jeremy
all married all advocates for marriage
most of us have been married you know
for a decade or more around there
Drew for a lot longer than that so my
point is simply that if you're
surrounded by miserable people who hate
their lives and their wives and their
marriages and that's everyone you know
then then then that's a reflection of
the people you choose to hang around and
that's actually a big part of the
problem I think
just choosing to hang around people who
are a drag they're just a drag on you
they're dysfunctional they live
dysfunctional lives they love to tell
you about it so we talked about in the
opening
you know complaining about if if you've
got people around you complaining about
their friends complaining about their
marriages complaining about their their
wives
my wife and I have disagreements we've
like in any marriage you know there's
going to be disagreements I'm never
gonna tell
any I don't complain about her to
anybody
I know there's this like sitcom
stereotype of men like always doing that
it's the Everybody Loves Raymond men are
just going around complaining about the
old ball and chain I don't do that and I
actually don't know that many people who
do that because that's not anyone else's
business I don't need to talk to you I
don't need to it's like in general I
don't need to complain to you about my
personal life about people that I know
like if I have an issue with my wife
I'll talk to her I'm gonna talk to you I
don't need I don't need to vent to you I
don't need to cry on your shoulder
same for anyone else who's close to me
if I have an issue with them I talk to
them I don't talk to you I don't talk to
anybody else
that's an in-house issue it's not for
anybody else's ears
so if you have men in your life if not
just men you if every man in your life
doesn't even respect that basic thing
you know the sanctity of of of of in the
privacy of the family then you need to
find some better quality people
um hey yes says don't worry Matt we're
raising our nine boys to act like men
and to not apologize for being one
strong responsible and moral men are
needed to lead Society for those who've
asked we also have four girls
wow uh that's incredible you've got me
you know
sometimes I like to think oh we've got a
big family six kids on the way that's
impressive and then I hear from people
like you with 13 kids and I realize that
we're just these are these are rookie
numbers we're putting up so
congratulations to you for that
um
Mandy Johnson says it's really tough
because all that Matt says about
relationships and marriage is true I got
married about 10 years ago while he's a
strong conservative he does have other
personal demons it's been a lot more
turmoil than happiness overall I've
learned a lot about myself though and
I'm still grateful I got married because
I've learned a lot of selflessness
godliness and patience that I never
would have learned being single marriage
is a huge risk especially nowadays
spiritually financially Etc well and
look not to not to Discount whatever
demons you're referring to and some
personal demons are more serious than
others that's for certain but everybody
does have them
and that's why it's our job in a
marriage to lift each other up you know
and do it in a loving way not a
you know this is this is one of the keys
for for and I'm not saying that you're
not doing this I don't know you but
this is one of the most important things
for women if you're if you're if there's
something
if your husband has a flaw which every
husband does just like every wife has a
flaw
it's okay to
work with him on that but you got to do
it with respect
that's I think this is this is one thing
that that many women tend to miss
because when you when you lose that
respect if it turns into nagging
that's what it all gets tuned out and
then that makes you frustrated because
then you say well I'm nagging them about
this all the time and he's not changing
yeah it's because it's the nagging part
we just don't listen to that it doesn't
matter what it is you could be so
incredibly right about whatever it is
you're saying if that's the tone and
approach we just don't listen
and we don't need to talk about whether
that's a fair response or not it just is
the response and it always will be the
response and so you've got to change and
you you have to change the way you
approach it
um
and
let's see finally grumpy head says I
don't know what is wrong with me but
when I heard Matt saying he would find
his wife and Mary are a hundred times
across all universes I couldn't hold my
tears damn those words are shockingly
melting me I came from a broken family
my parents were separated shortly after
I was born and now my 30s and married
but trust issues is still an effing
curse to me I added green psychology I'm
applying everything I know trying to fix
myself and trying to do any harm not do
any harm to my current relationship like
I did before when I was dumb young
selfish b word
I always need to be alarmed and have my
self-awareness fully on what I when I'm
feeling anxious really trying to be a
good wife and I love my husband so much
I don't hate my parents at all I'm happy
for them because they did the right
thing for themselves they only find
peace with each other indeed however the
damage from my original family can never
fade away in my life well
here's the good news is that you you
have self-awareness so you're aware
you know if you love your husband
you're struggling but you love your
husband you love your marriage you're
trying to preserve it you're aware of
what your own flaws are you're trying to
work on them that's that that puts you
far ahead of the game compared to many
people
so that's a good news sign copies of my
books what is a woman and Johnny The
Walrus are back in stock and available
in a limited quantity quantity over at
dailywire.com shop now is not only a
chance to secure the book version of my
LGBT death cult melting documentary and
my best-selling LGBT magnum opus but
also pieces of Sweet Baby history you
can get them before they're gone by
heading over to dailywire.com shop today
also if there's one thing to be learned
from the release of the Twitter files
it's that the mainstream media cannot be
trusted you know it we know it and now
Millions more people are waking up to it
so no surprise that morning wire the
daily wire's fastest growing news
podcast is continuing to climb the
charts with new episodes seven days a
week join editor-in-chief John Bickley
with Coach JoJo Howe as they cut through
the corporate agendas and manufactured
outrage to bring you the facts first on
all the news you need to know wake up
with morning wire and apple on a daily
wire plus Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts now
let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
during one of these daily cancellation
segments last week we discussed the
violent nature of football and other
contact Sports a violent nature which
had come under intense scrutiny by the
media after as we talked about Bill's
Defender Demar Hamlin nearly died on the
field during a Sunday Night Football
matchup with Cincinnati Bengals of
course as far as we know the Hamline
incident may not have any had anything
to do with football violence still to
this point all we know is that he had a
cardiac emergency in the middle of the
game we have not been given any direct
evidence
that it was actually caused by a
collision on the field though it
certainly could have been either way
whatever the exact cause it remains an
extremely rare occurrence that anyone
has to be you know anyone has anyone has
to be taken off the field by an
ambulance and brought immediately to the
hospital that's rare it doesn't happen
very often
this in spite of the fact that football
is indeed a violent Sport and as I
argued during that segment it should
remain a violent sport
now it's good to have these kinds of
physical even brutal full contact Sports
if for no other reason than the fact
that they serve as relatively healthy
relatively safe relatively productive
Outlets
for male aggression one of the great
services that sports like football
provide for societies that they give
young aggressive man men and boys a way
to harness and Channel all of that
energy this is one of the central
reasons why Sports exist to begin with
the violence is not the whole point but
it is part of the point and it's an
important part
take it away and these young men will
find other outlets for their aggression
Outlets which you will discover are not
nearly so safe or controlled as football
that was my basic point and it was a
point that proved to be very upsetting
to people on the internet especially
after our marketing team at Media
Matters posted another of their
carefully cropped clips of my monologue
to Twitter
the full monologue which fleshes out my
point in rather precise detail went on
for I think 12 or 13 minutes but Jason
Campbell and Media Matters posted the 75
seconds which he felt was the most
likely to make the Pitchfork mob upset
especially when isolated from the full
context
and it seems that he made the right
choice because his clip garnered nearly
10 million views on Twitter and provoked
lots of angry reactions
before we continue I think it should be
it would be fair for me to you know
go back and we'll show the part of that
monologue that he posted and then we'll
talk about it here he is
let's consider football itself as a
sport
despite any rule changes or updates to
the equipment it is still a
fundamentally violent sport that's true
and and that's what it always will be
is that a bad thing no it's not
in fact it is a good and healthy thing
it is good that football is violent it
should stay violent it is good to have
violent Sports
okay we should have violent Sports if
anything we should have more of them
because a violent sport like football is
among other things
a relatively safe relatively safe and
relatively productive outlets for male
energy and aggression
okay there's a reason why many of the
media articles being written and
freaking out about football are being
written by women
because football is not no matter what
the NFL is trying to do football is not
for women there might be some women who
get into it but it's not really forward
it's not for you you don't understand it
you're not meant to understand it this
is actually a man's thing
this is why violent games have existed
in every society going back to primitive
times they are a means of channeling and
harnessing male aggression
okay so I did say that football is a
man's sport
which uh you know why did I say that how
could I possibly justify such a
statement well because football was
invented by men and has been played
almost exclusively by men and the vast
majority of its fans are men and have
always been men and will always be men
that's why I said that does that mean
that no woman has ever watched football
or been a fan or been involved
professionally at some level no it just
means that football was made by men
and mostly four men this is a
statistical and historical reality it
isn't really up for debate okay if it
interferes with your girl power
fantasies that's your problem not mine I
don't really care
and apparently it did interfere with
lots of people's fantasies which is why
there were many tweets explaining why my
statements were terrible and wrong and
hurtful and sexist and so on
this continued this continued until the
scholars over at The Young Turks got
wind of the controversy and decided to
devote a lengthy segment responding to
and supposedly debunking my claims the
title of this segment on YouTube
declares that quote tyt demolishes
right-wing alpha male Matt Walsh for his
most recent sexist rants
this is nothing new I've been demolished
by many a left-wing YouTuber over the
years demolished at least according to
the titles they put on their videos
but as we've seen many times in the past
these demolitions usually end up being
rather uh anti-climactic if I must say
rarely do they live up to their own hype
perhaps though this young Turks video
will be different perhaps my demolition
will finally come to fruition
let's watch and find out
that is the infamous fascist misogynist
and other badist Matt Walsh
insisting that football is only for men
and we are about to prove him completely
wrong who could have seen that take
coming uh Jake did called it perfectly
just yesterday right here on tyt check
out this clip
so now it looks like the right wing is
trying to frame it like I I remember
when people were real men and they just
didn't mind people getting killed on the
field now the lips want to make this
soft so there isn't as many deaths on
the field
[Music]
thank God you're wearing a slightly
different colored shirt otherwise people
could have thought you did that live but
yeah no I I knew they were gonna
eventually celebrate the guy either the
fact they own the guy almost died right
and like oh it's supposed to be a
voicemail yeah and chicks wouldn't
understand nothing about it huh
my favorite thing about this dude is
that his dumb guy voice is
indistinguishable from his regular voice
he's doing an impression of an idiot and
yet sounds just like himself and
speaking of sounding like an idiot he
misses the point entirely of course if
if there is a right-wing take on the
Demar Hamlin injury it's that it's not
an injury
Jank is that how you pronounce I
honestly don't know how to pronounce his
name he's trying to straw man us but
he's hilariously using the wrong straw
man if there was a conservative position
on this topic which there isn't okay
because it's not a political issue but
if there was it would be that Hamlin
collapsed for reasons wholly unrelated
to football the predominant view among
conservative pundits on the internet
from what I've seen is that I'm much
more plugged into that world than he is
is that this may have had something to
do with the vaccine
whether that's wrong or right like
that's when it comes to the Demar Hamlin
thing that's the thing that most
conservatives were talking about very
few are using this as an occasion to
defend violent Sports I am but I'm not
the official spokesman for conservative
pundits and none of us are as he says
celebrating the fact that the guy almost
died that's not happening anywhere so we
were promised a demolition and instead
so far we've gotten a series of
completely arbitrary and irrelevant
strawmen that bear not even a passing
resemblance to any argument that anyone
has ever actually made not a great start
but uh let's continue
this video had two parts right so over
there really three parts one is not so
bad he's saying look it's a societally
acceptable way of uh releasing uh some
of the violent urges uh that people of
society and men in particular have
that's not that wrong right but when
they celebrate the second part is
celebrating like oh violence is a good
thing yeah oh yeah this car it's great
no but wait it doesn't have to be this
violent they talked about a little bit
yesterday I'll just tell you real quick
between 1900 and 1905 45 different
people died on the football field
because it used to be even more violent
they would literally kill each other on
the field and guess what happened the
government stepped in it was Teddy
Roosevelt when he was president and said
I'm not going to let you kill each other
on the field like this this is insane
you have to make it less violent and you
know what happened after that it became
way more popular because people didn't
want to go see a sport and have people
murder each other on the field and so it
doesn't mean it's going to be less
popular doesn't mean it's going to be a
less of a sport or anything along those
lines if you don't celebrate people like
Demar Hamlin almost dying on the field
oh okay I get it so so this is I see
what's happening here this is the exact
opposite of a demolition actually he
agrees with my argument but is trying to
find a way to disagree with it he
concedes my point about football being a
healthy outlet for male aggression that
was essentially my entire point so if he
will admit that I'm right or his words
not that wrong then there's not much
else to talk about but he keeps talking
anyway even after having long since run
out of anything relevant to say as is is
custom he observes that um
football used to be a lot more violent
than it is today if that sounds familiar
it's probably because I made the exact
same point in the very monologue he's
attempting to rebut
that's what I said
it's the left-wing media that tried to
turn Damar Hamlin into a conversation
about football's increasing violence
remember a White House reporter asked
the president about the you know his
football becoming too dangerous
as I said in that segment football is
actually becoming much less dangerous if
there was a time to have a national
dialogue about the violence in football
it was 50 years ago or a hundred years
ago
today it's about as non-violent as it
can possibly be while still remaining
something resembling the sport as it was
originally designed the Hamlin injury if
it was a football injury was the result
of a routine football play that was by
no means especially violent or brutal
there would be no way to take that play
out of the game without turning it into
a two-hand touch or flag football
which is why once again it makes no
sense to use Demar Hamlin as a jumping
off point for a discussion about the
violence of the sport it has nothing to
do with the violence of the sport
it was a it was a basic normal tackle
that's all it was
it was a not especially violent play in
a sport that has become less and less
violent with each passing year that was
my point a point that Jank restates
while pretending to rebut
but now it's time for the woman on the
panel to chime in and she's the one okay
this is where they're setting her up
okay they're teeing her off and uh but
this is where the real demolition is
going to happen she is going to set me
straight let's listen
okay so his the Crux of his argument is
women shouldn't have a say because men
are the ones that have violent urges and
you chicks don't get it your chicks
don't get the violent urges that we have
that we need to get out which I almost
can see like I'm a CIS woman and I am
raising apparently so far as I know a
CIS baby I've been raising a CIS son for
two years and there are like yeah I
totally get that there are like male
things that are ingrained in him
I would I would actually almost accept
that argument from this Tool Shed if I
knew that he had no opinions on abortion
female reproductive rights uh the price
of tampons you know maternity leave if
he shut his stupid bearded pie hole
about any of those things that he
literally is a man does not understand
about being a woman then I might accept
his argument but I know this
bearded
douche nozzle has so much to say about
women that he knows nothing about so for
him to turn around be like women I don't
even want to hear from you because you
guys just don't shut up shut your stupid
dumb pie hole you dime stored
Justin Thoreau
lady listen if you want to be included
in the football conversation you're not
helping your case here you're so
emotional you can barely see straight
calm down cupcake take a breath you're
being hysterical
okay can you imagine trying to watch a
game and this woman comes running in
you're trying to watch the game let me
tell you about my CIS baby
my God shut up
now as to your points if anything in
that rambling stuttering pile of words
can be described as a point I would say
this
first of all I do not now have nor have
I ever had an opinion about the price of
tampons
I don't even know how much they cost I
couldn't tell you
is it is it three dollars a tampon I
don't know 30 cents
I do have an opinion about abortion and
other reproductive quote unquote
reproductive issues because as a man I
am 50 involved in reproduction
it is as much my issue as it is yours
I was also once an unborn baby
so if you want reproduction to be a
woman's issue you need to figure out a
way to reproduce entirely without the
involvement of a male member of the
species until you do that
this is our issue as much as it is yours
so you got to deal with that actually
let me clarify that you have to figure
out a way to reproduce without a male
member of the species and also to
reproduce yourself
because if you're reproducing and making
another person
then already it's not just your issue
because there's another person involved
so no matter what in reproduction there
are other people involved it's not just
you
second to clarify
I don't disregard your opinion about
football
I don't
I disregard your opinion about
everything
including football
not because you're a woman but because
you use the phrase CIS baby
that automatically I want you to
understand this that automatically
invalidates everything you will ever say
about anything ever
not that on this topic you actually have
much to say in the first place you've
yet to approach anything that might be
called an argument but but still
everything's out the window now
because you talked about your CIS baby
but anyway you know what we'll listen
for another minute to give you one last
chance to put together some kind of
argument let's go
he's just saying women what
are not intelligent enough to understand
football what do you mean they can't
understand yeah there's there's it's not
that complicated there's literally
posted rules like you can Google the
rules of football and anyone with like
basic level of intelligence cannot
there's literally a list of rules and go
okay I understand if you watch you read
the rules you watch one game and go I
get it I get it it's not magic it's not
magic you know it's not like do are men
not allowed to watch
gymnastics or baking or like this is the
most sexist going both ways sexist
argument from the dumbest douche nozzle
okay this is what tells me that not only
are you unable to understand football
but apparently you also don't understand
English
I didn't say that women can't comprehend
the rules of football I mean you
probably can't which is why you're
sitting there Googling it
what I said quite clearly from the
context is that women generally don't
understand don't relate to the desire to
watch much less participate in violence
as entertainment
males understand violence as
entertainment in a way that women don't
just like my wife understands the appeal
of Gilmore Girl reruns in a way that I
don't
the urge to seek outlets for that sort
of physical aggression is something that
males experience and relate to much more
than females there are exceptions
but the exceptions are exceptions that's
why we call them exceptions
is that clear enough for you or are you
still confused do I need to speak slower
in conclusion the Young Turk Squad here
has spent 10 minutes trying to find a
reason to disagree with my point but
sadly they never found one
all we've really learned here is that
they have trouble comprehending simple
English sentences we've also learned
that the woman at the table has a baby
who we should all be praying for and
we've learned that all three of them at
the table are today canceled but I'll do
it for this portion of the show as we
move over to the members block you can
become a member and watch the members
block by using Code wall should check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
hopesee over there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you